Mary here with a gamespot news update it
looks like The Witcher threes
performance has taken a hit on consoles
due to the latest patch following the
release of the feature-rich one point 0
7 update for the witcher 3 wild hunt
this weekend a technical analysis has
revealed that the update impacts console
performance with other issues reported
as well Digital foundries technical
breakdown of the one point 07 patch
reveals that the framerate on both xbox
one and playstation 4 have been
negatively impacted in some areas
digital foundry explained some of the
issues essentially gameplay on Xbox one
now appears to rely on a similar double
buffer vsync set up to the ps4 game
walking its frame rate to 20 FPS during
these lolz and performance this means
that the reading on our graph is
consistently lower on patch 1.07 as
compared to one point 05 where it was
free to waver between 20 to 30 FPS
freely frame rate for the witcher threes
pc version doesn't appear to be affected
by the new update however some PC
players who bought the game through
developer CD projekt red's own site GOG
calm as well as steam are reporting that
achievements are not working as they
should performance issues aside this
giant patch has added lots of useful
features such as an alternate better
movement system for garel and several
inventory management options you could
decide to hold off on installing that
patch but life is so much better with
that book tab so the latest news be sure
to head to gamespot com
you